you can hear him right a few guys
adorable you're adorable
they can't understand me kids and no one
else here I told me to Pokemon and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet
what is that silent but deadly apologies
my tummy's bad from all the coffee in
Pokemon detective Pikachu
welcome to Rimes City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
town
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are
you know how to use this jeez here we go
I know you can't understand me but put
down the stapler or I will electrocute
you did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me I've been so lonely they
try to talk to me all the time all they
hear is pika pika you can hear him right
you're adorable they can't understand me
kiss you no one else I don't need a
Pokemon period and what about a
world-class detective because if you
want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving you
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]